support move University in the
production of more video tutorials by
making a financial contribution or by
getting yourself one of these t-shirts
details under the support move section
on move University calm the link will be
in the description below thank you and
enjoy alright so we've talked about the
idea of certainty versus uncertainty and
we're talking about significant figures
now I want to talk about precision
accuracy and error and how that plays
into the idea of serving too so
certainty can basically be divided into
precision and accuracy and what are
these things sort of what do they mean I
will hear these words sometimes but what
are they we were talking about them in
terms of science and measurements
precision describes reproducibility
reproducibility of measurements or how
close measured values are to each other
whereas accuracy describes how close a
measured value is to the actual value or
the true value so what does that mean
okay well let's think about this in
terms of the classic way to describe
this is an auditory board or a dart
board I'm going to talk about as if its
arch report ok so the target of course
is the center that's the bullseye right
and we want to hit that with our arrows
so let's say we're shooting five arrows
ok let's say we shoot five arrows and
this is where they hit right here one
two three four five they all hit right
there in this case we've got a case we
have we have lots of let's call
precision p let's call accuracy a so
here this is very precise very precise
but very low in accuracy right high
precision low accuracy because low
accuracy because the actual target is
that center right the bullseye and we're
really far away from it right we're
really precise because every single
every single shot is
they're really really close to each
other the reproducibility there of the
measurements is really really high right
if you imagine that in a lab measuring
the same value over and over and over so
in this case this is very precise but
inaccurate okay now what about the
opposite case could we have a case in
which we have a low precision and high
accuracy kind of but not really I mean
this is as close as it gets to it let's
say we want to be more accurate right
let's say we hit those five shots and
they end up being here here here here
and here okay so here this is more
accurate because we're closer to the
actual value the actual target right the
actual bullseye but we're not as precise
our values a little bit further away
from each other now notice it's still
fairly precise because these values are
kind of close to each other but over
here they were like a one you know one
tiny bunch whereas here to spread out a
little bit more right so this is less
precise but more accurate okay the ideal
would of course be to have to have high
precision and high accuracy right and in
that case we'd have maybe all five hits
dead center one two three four five you
can even tell that I'm putting five
little dots or fine little stars there
right that would be highly precise
because all the values are there all the
shots are there and highly accurate
because they're all at the true place
where we want them to be of course we
could have a case where we could have it
you know low precision and low accuracy
right with shots all over the place and
not even close to the bullseye right
let's just do a quick example of that if
we had like a shot here or shot here
shot here a shot here and a shot here
that's not precise or accurate right and
green there because they're not reap
they're not all in the same place and
they're all far away from that's far
away from the the actual goal or target
so that would be inaccurate and not
precise now aside from that precision
and accuracy are also defined in terms
the two types of errors that we're going
to this the two types of error that
we're going to discuss here in this
video those two are random error and
systematic error so what is random error
random error is when measured values are
both higher then actual values and lower
than actual values okay so this is both
right when when measured values are both
higher both higher and lower than actual
value so you get values from you get
measurements that are higher than what
the true value is and lower than what
the true value is and this always occurs
this random error always occurs and it
depends on how skilled an individual is
at taking measurements and and the
precision of the instruments that are
used to take the measurements so when we
talk about precise measurements precise
measurements are defined as having low
random error because they are they are
their precise when you could reproduce
the same value over and over and over
right but if you have a specific target
value right the accurate value and you
have values that are measured above it
and values that are better below it then
you're not being precise right you're
not getting them all basically in the
same same spot okay so precise
measurements have low random error so
they're defined in that in that way when
it comes to systematic error systematic
error that's when measured values are
either either all higher than the actual
value or all lower than the actual
values were here this is an either/or
situation unlike with random error right
before it was both higher and lower you
would systematic error either all the
values that you measure are higher or
all of them are lower right and this can
be due to something else this is not
this is this can be due to faulty
measuring equipment or devices that are
that are used to take the measurements
alright um or a particular individual
that's taking these measurements is root
is consistently repeating the same
mistake when they're making that
measurement right so this can be
accounted for and reduced slightly and
hopefully eliminate it to be honest bye
bye calibration of of the equipment
that's used or the devices that are used
to make the measurements and calibration
basically means that you're taking this
equipment or these devices and setting
them to a known standard to make them
you know capable of taking as close to
correct measurements as possible and so
when it comes to accurate measurements
accurate measurements have low
systematic error and they usually have
low random error as well and usually
have low random error as well and the
reason for this is that you know it's
it's if you're accurate you're probably
also precise right like if you if you
take five measurements and they're all
pretty much right on the money right
well they're all around the same area
right so that if they're accurate
they're probably also precise so that's
why I add this little pink part here and
usually above and amaris well so I hope
that video was helpful and kind of
wrapping that up thank you for watching
if you found that video helpful be sure
to video with the like and don't forget
to subscribe if you haven't already also
be sure to share the video with anyone
of you think might find it helpful
thanks and happy studying